You've probably heard the word engineering before...
...and you've probably been told it's pretty important.
But what exactly is engineering?
And who exactly is an engineer?
Engineers are people who design and build things that we use every day.
However, they don't just go building the first thing that comes to mind.
They work hard to make something we need and they want to do a good job of it.
So how do engineers decide what they need to build?
Well, in most cases, they start with a question.
Here's an example.
Say you live on a space station and something outside breaks.
Obviously, you need to go outside and fix it.
But how exactly do you do that?
That's a great question for engineers.
Once they've got a good handle on things, they'll start imagining ways to solve the problem.
They'll come up with all kinds of ideas and some that might even seem a little crazy.
That's important because sometimes the craziest idea is the one that works best.
After coming up with these ideas, they'll pick a few that make the most sense.
Next, they'll start drawing a plan.
Depending on the idea, the plan can be very simple or very complicated.
But the important part is the plan itself.
A good plan helps engineers focus on what they're making and most importantly, why.